I'm 22 and and my energies right now
focused on my career and and I'm just
trying to set up the base for my life
that I think everyone does when they're
in their early 20s dad that was et's
first interview with Michael J Fox back
in 1984 on the set of family ties now
since then we have followed Fox's
Hollywood career and of course his
real-life battle with Parkinson's
disease on our Brooke Anderson was
invited to talk to Michael and his wife
Tracy Pollan inside their New York home
it's an ET exclusive how was your health
today how are you doing at the moment
infinitely what we call off which is uh
my meds I'm working they kick in as soon
as we're done it was 27 years ago when a
doctor first diagnosed a tremor in his
pinky finger as the beginning of
Parkinson's how do you both cope with
the tough days well this is one of them
yeah I mean it's not tough days are not
really you don't know exactly
I feel like however I am it's really a
take the acceptance but you have to
recognize it is where it is 99% of the
rest of my life is my Parkinson's edit
other stuff and that keeps me busy and I
know I don't cease to be to feel sorry
for myself but it wasn't always so
positive about life he once abused
alcohol as a way of coping with the
disease one time I woke up with a
hangover and then expected Tracy be mad
at me and she wasn't angry she was just
bored and and that to me was more
frightening than anything is that how
you felt I'm not I didn't scream I
didn't I wasn't angry I was kind of
feeling done they worked through it as
he and Tracy recently celebrated 30
years as husband and wife
with her love and support he was able to
regain sobriety and pursue his mission
of helping others with the disease
through all the trials and tribulations
how have you made that marriage work
it's so cliche but we just really like
he's in the room
we're most happy in each other's company
I love you all right I love you I love
you I love you
the two met back when she was cast as
Michaels love interest on family ties
you have said that you had this huge
crush on Tracy do you still have that
crush on more than ever every day this
weekend Michael and his family all
attended the annual gala for his
foundation the event was called a funny
thing happened on the way to cure
Parkinson's the youngest Fox girl is
still in high school their twin
daughters recently graduated college and
lookalike son Sam is hoping to become an
agent
well mostly his advice is you know be
myself and and really sort of understand
what it is that I'm doing which which is
what I'm trying to do since Michael
created the Michael J Fox foundation
nearly 20 years ago it has raised over
800 million dollars for research it's
not about building up a foundation for
the greater glory of me or the greater
glory of scientists but they actually do
the work and include the patient
community in it every step of the way
which we do what is the most important
lesson you have learned from the disease
just to treasure every day and and don't
look at it literally don't look at the
glass as half-empty
look at this half-full if it's half-full
there's still more there there's some
more taste and somewhere to enjoy
[Music]